[Music]
it took about two and a half hours all
the makeup they gave me these huge traps
right and it was funny because they used
to work out in Venice Beach everybody
said before you taking roids no it was
makeup food you know
[Music]
our problem is take the bank or split
right now do not go home do not pack
nothing 30 seconds flat from now we are
gone on our separate ways that's it
Michael Mann did a film in Folsom Prison
it's called the Jericho Mile and he made
friends with my uncle Michael Gilbert he
won't admit it but he paid my uncle
Gilbert sag wages for the three weeks
that they were in Folsom and Gilbert
kept everybody in line and so when I
showed up on the set of heat and it was
funny because he saw me hey Gilbert no
not me Danny and but he kept mistaking
me for Gilbert and he changed the script
three times he gave me three different
names and every time he changed the
names change the whole script so a lot
of trees went down you know and uh
finally he came up to me and said Danny
you know what every time I look at you I
think of your uncle Gilbert is it okay
if I just call you Gilbert Trejo in the
movie yeah my whole family right because
Gilbert had died you know he said oh
deed and died since before then and uh
so if you know my my name in the movies
Gilbert Trail I can try to dump them
again how are we going to know if you
did
it didn't you drum toss
that's a Ventura pull them out of here
all right hey I'm sorry man last thing I
want to do is let you down
that day first day D call me and said
Danny you know what you have to come
down to the set blah blah I said hey
homie it's my day off I said would you
please tell Michael Mann that he owes me
big time so I showed up in a sweat suit
and and a sweatshirt because I was and
he says okay that's good that's good to
leave there and that ring that you see
in the movie my kid wears that now
please don't
leave me like this and it was funny
because when we were gonna do that scene
Robert veneers is a how do you want to
play this I don't know Bob what do you
think and he just gets you know I think
you're almost dead Trejo I think they
almost beat you to death and you're just
got enough to beg me to kill you for a
split second I was ah Bob I don't know I
I got a little different but it's Bob De
Niro you know what hey just what I
thought he had great you know and so we
did it like that and it it was iconic
death scene but my daughter still can't
watch that scene and I said I want you
through how come you you seen me dying
from Dusk to Dawn my eyes went in the
pool pocket she said because that's the
way you were supposed to die dad you
know that's the way you lived and I
thought wow yeah I guess you're right
you know so
Conair
with muscle criminal I mean
is funny because they put all the
wannabe tough guys in a plane in
Hollywood and because lunch turned into
a big who's got the biggest huevos you
know I mean just because they were like
somebody spent somebody else with them
pretty soon everybody it was a spinning
contest if you did a push-up everybody
tried to do more push it became a big
contest right and uh and they tried to
bait you into things this ain't
happening out here not loud what's
happening hey relax he's right not here
not now do you fly Johnny they had Benny
yukitis who was you know five-time world
champion kickboxer John Cusack you know
people don't know because he looks like
oh wait what John Cusack would kick ass
and uh Benny's is Sensei so they had a
dojo setup I grew up with Benny's older
brother who taught him karate you know
what I mean and he said you know what
Danny you're like my brother first of
all you're not not a good sport and you
don't get along well with others so you
don't want to you know you're gonna end
up you know sucking somebody so
[Music]
bloody and blood out
[Music]
I love that movie and I love what it did
for the Latino Community showing that
because Blood In Blood Out showed three
main characters and you know one ended
up a police officer one ended up an
artist wanted up in prison I read Taylor
hackford's script and I knew that it was
a movie not kind of like a documentary
it was funny because the cast they were
all like
trained thespians every time I'd come
around they start talking about like
like Juan Strasburg or somebody you know
a player that they'd done or something
and I never did any of that [ __ ] you
know I just showed up and started
working and so uh my friend George Perry
uh said that when we get to San Quentin
we got to San Quentin it like it changed
there's nothing scarier than when you
walk into San Quentin upper yard and you
got 3 000 convicts on this side
screaming about
how pretty you are most of that cast was
pretty you know and I looked around and
they were all like just kind of like
close behind me
because they seen that I knew what was
happening here and then uh some of the
the actors learned that it's all about
respect everything it's all about
respect I love it when you walk on a set
of a movie and they're portraying
convicts and everybody's like yeah
pushing everybody out of the way and
being tough and being me it's not like
that I had to pull a couple of people
aside and
tell them hey look who's I'm not
Hollywood you know because people like
actors like try to stay in character you
know what I mean and and if we're
playing prisoners bad guys and we're
dinner or we're at lunch hey Pastor saw
man you know what get your mother to
pass us off fool who do you think you're
talking it's like I don't talk to people
that way would you please pass a song
you know if you're a killer and I'm a
killer it's best to say hey excuse me
and and you know if it if it comes to
something well then we kill each other
but we don't want to get there you know
so really prison is probably the most
polite place in the world but you know
step out of line he'll kill you
Desperado
[Music]
when I went to cast for that I I walked
into Robert Rodriguez's office in Venice
and his words were wow you remind me of
the bad guys in my high school and yeah
what he says I am the bad guys in your
high school and so he just handed me a
knife he said here twirl that I just
started twirling it and I got back to my
house and I asked my agent calls me what
happened I said I don't know he gave me
a knife I got so good with that knife
just rolling I walked on a plane with it
keep this up it's going to be over and
believe me it's going to be over real
quick
[Music]
Robert Rodriguez gave me a compliment
one time and he said you can say more
with your face than most actors can say
with a page of dialogue that's a hell of
a compliment you know and it's funny but
that takes practice because like in San
Quentin sometimes I think you got to be
able to say hey I'll kill you without
saying a word and so once you master
that people seem to stay away from you
because they're just not quite sure
Antonio Banderas was Spanish and Spanish
has a very elegant dialect and we're in
Mexico you know we're in in Acuna Mexico
which is a a little Border Town and so a
lot of people didn't gravitate toward
him there there everybody gravitated
towards me and I was assigning
autographs and taking pictures and and
everybody should take off your shirt
because of my big tattoo and Robert says
hey they think you're the star of this
movie I said you mean I'm not my uncle
who stopped to visit you know they came
to visit me and and my uncle kind of
said hey who's that that guy you know I
said Robert Rodriguez he's the director
and I remember he goes to Robert hey and
he goes like this and that's the
director looking but Robert being
amazing you know when an older person
calls you you just he just showed he
came and showed up you know respect him
and he started talking and then all of a
sudden Robert says hey I mean my uncle
said hey say hello to your cousin you
know I found out that Robert Rodriguez
was my second cousin so I immediately
said okay let's make my part bigger
because you know we've done like 13
movies together right there you know
what this movie that I want to do and he
ran down machete to me and yeah we can
do that'd be cool
From Dusk to Dawn
is for bikers and truckers only
the dust the dawn I stole the movie Man
the movie was so real it's like you
couldn't help it being real and then
George Clooney was unbelievable he was
that was his first movie God man five
six years later he did a film called uh
up in the air and I just went to the
premiere I just and he started screaming
you know Trey oh hey come here and he
starts he starts giving them my report
hey he was in my first movie and I'd be
like oh this is George Clooney
Spy Kids machete he will turn around
you will leave my shot
if I never want to hear my brother's
name mentioned again sure our uncle
a real Uncle cause swear I got fake Coco
five six year old kids are still
watching that it's Timeless I mean I had
six and seven-year-old kids in the
airport wanting autographs signing Uncle
machete you know so he's like it's still
gone they needed trailers for Grindhouse
and they needed a fake trailers so we
put a we put machete in the trailer if
you're gonna hire a machete to kill the
bad guy you better make damn sure the
bad guy
isn't you
when we walked out of the theater
everybody said we have to do that movie
so and if you notice everything that was
in the trailer we just put it in the
movie so it
[Applause]
[Music]
the first Halloween after a machete I'd
opened the door to give kids candy and a
lot of Mexican kids were dressed as
machete
mustache and they see me it ain't much
yet it was like it was just kind of kind
of cool you know it's like we had little
Mexican kids that didn't have to meet
Batman or or or Superman you know they
were like machete you know so it was
kind of cool
King of the Hill
Hank my marriage is falling apart I'm so
unhappy I don't know what to do you're
the only one in the world like a dirt do
okay then I'll see it work
the guy that did it might judge judge
right judge yeah well he made the Native
American guy right but he put
a tattoo on him like this and the tattoo
was exactly like the hat that I've got
okay I'm gonna need twenty dollars now
and twenty dollars when it is done and
another twenty dollars for expenses so I
said all right
judge because he came on the set of
Machete and I said okay hey Judd check
this out you got my tattoo done is that
give me like residuals or something you
know and he goes no no no I got you a
character so the next week is like all
of a sudden the character was this guy
name of Enrique right but I played on
that for a while Hank Hill is my best
friend and I work for Strickland propane
Pig it's salmon they put salmon in the
fish tacos hey what are you talking
about
look at it it's Solomon they're ruining
everything so it was cool and I met uh
Brittany Murphy and she's the one it's
like what's good about voiceover you can
show up in pajamas yeah it doesn't
matter she's never coming with fluffy
slippers and he was like you did you
know makeup you just do it
[Music]
Rick and Morty
there is no Freedom while your leader
breathes our country is a prison and
Katarina is a prisoner perhaps I could
arrange her Escape as well
she lives Jaguar
where is this pickle you know like I
really don't watch Rick and Morty you
know and uh my son got me to do that and
they were asking me to do it and dad you
got to do everybody I do that and it
went viral my son he just got into the
DGA for directing and uh he's been
directing music videos he directed me in
a film called from a son that hasn't
come out yet but it's the only movie
I've ever cried in
badass
[Music]
this Deuces the back take them but leave
him alone
badass I did as a favorite remember I
told you everything good that's happened
to me happened as a direct result of
helping someone else they had me up for
this film that was paying big dough okay
and then badass came along well you know
they say one in the hand is worth two in
the bush anyway but my Asian Gloria kept
saying Danny this is going to turn into
something turned into a Trilogy I did
badass badasses badass on the by you
made four times the money I was gonna
make on that one but on the first one I
met a director named Ash Shaw who had
been in the restaurant business and he
saw that I I like eating good food I
won't eat you know the Jack or the Mac
I'd always bring a little salad or I'd
bring something to eat that and he said
why don't you open a restaurant Danny
jokingly I said Trejo's tacos you know I
just thought TT would look great in
diamonds he brought me a business plan I
gave it to Glory area and she kind of
said it's a no-brainer Danny this is the
first time somebody wants you to do
something they're not asking for 100
grand up front so we've got four
restaurants right now we're opening up
one right now in Detroit with a venue
like House of Blues Restaurant and
Stadium next to it
it's a wonderful binge hey ah come with
me if you want a binge
at first I didn't understand it and
that's wait a minute because I didn't
see binge right so I said this is like
the reverse of It's a Wonderful Life
that was a lot of fun just it was
freezing cold we're under a bridge and
it was already freezing gold who are you
man hey I'm angel angel like I think
you're my angel if that's what you want
to hear kids now what's your problem we
kept on each other you start saying
something and I go wow you know what
you'd be really pretty in the pan and he
wouldn't know what to say
so so he kind of stopped challenging me
[Music]
Breaking Bad
[Music]
[Music]
I love it and you know what Tortuga it
was received so well that read another
one and called me back and did the first
part when I was in London these guys
came up with this tortoise about this
big it took three guys to carry his huge
and they said we'll give you 500 if you
sign it you got it so I signed it
Tortuga and then your hola DEA you know
and made myself
hey white boy
my name is Tortuga
you know what that means
turtle
that's me
I take my time yeah I remember that
scene was awesome when I was sitting in
the bed talking to the feds
yeah I'm slow but I always win I'm dead